you look gorgeous thank you never never
missed a carpet like okay how are you
feeling we're at the culmination of the
skywalker so I'm feeling very excited my
adrenaline is like oh I'm feeling me I'm
feeling the energy and the vibes I feel
very good I'm very excited the vibes are
good yeah what will you miss most about
this probably just hanging out with my
friends in space you know I mean all
those moments where you're looking
around set and being like this is crazy
and sharing that with people I think I'm
gonna miss that yeah I'm ready for I'm
ready to see what Rose has in store for
us have you seen have you seen the final
no I have yes yes I have
what was your face Daisy's changed
obviously Daisy said she cried and then
went home and watched friends to calm
down I did cry it was it's very much
very much friends is a good choice I've
been watching a lot of like bad
Christmas movies to your help that's
badass my move what is sure it's my
favorite genre is bad Christmas movies
yes what is your favorite Merry
Christmas
there's this monologue at the end an
elevator it's just gold pure gold okay
the fans have been out pouring their
love for you what is that that mean to
you on this this press tour
oh man it means so much I mean I think
that we're all just kind of reminding
ourselves that we're in this thing
that's so much bigger than us but
moments like that are just inexplicable
like you'll never forget that me know it
means a lot
having seen the movie are you are you
happy about Rose's arc I think that
we're all gonna be really happy with
what this movie does
[Music]